it's no secret that a lot of gamers have
a love-hate relationship with EA chances
are they have a hand in some of your
favorite games but they've also had
something of an issue with putting
gamers before their giant piles of money
nonetheless that's all supposed to
change within you play a first culture
initially discussed in june of this year
by new AAA CEO andrew wilson the plan is
to involve gamers in the development
process earlier only release games when
they're great and ready and support
their games for months after release
among other things the concept is part
of a three-year plan for EA but given
that we're now three months on from air
taking their player first culture public
I figured we'd see how they're going so
let's start with where all this EA hate
has come from EA won The Consumerist
snot so coveted worst company in america
award two years running where they were
up against evil banking conglomerates
airlines cell phone providers and all
the other multinational corporations who
screw people over on a daily basis this
year EA was defeated by the wildly
unpopular Comcast suspected reasons as
to why EA won the award in 2012 and 2013
include the massive controversy over the
mass effect 3 ending EAS prevalent love
of day 1 dlc the catastrophic launchers
and server issues of SimCity and
battlefield 4 peppering dead space 3
with microtransactions a tendency to
nickel and dime their players on the
hole and the unwillingness to admit
fault in regard to a bunch of these
controversial issues perhaps the
consumers themselves said it best
explaining when we live in an era marked
by massive oil spills faulty
foreclosures by bad banks and rampant
consolidation in the airline in telecom
industry what does that say about ea's
business practices that so many people
have for the second year in a row come
out to hand it the title of worst
company in America so they've already
started turning it around by not winning
the award this year but how are they
going in terms of keeping gamers updated
with the development
of their games in this field my
immediate reaction is that they're not
doing too badly he opens up battlefield
hardline to gamers in advance via the
June public beta although hardline was
pushed back to 2015 this still backs up
EAS player first culture in a couple of
ways first up EA have said they don't
want to release again that isn't good
enough and the feedback from gamers who
play the shooter back in June suggested
that hard line could be improved it also
reinforces the idea that EA actually
give a crap what you thought of their
game which let's be honest they haven't
always seemed to in the past the final
product of battlefield hardline remains
to be seen as yet so let's talk he is
too big releases within the last three
months of EAS player first mentality the
sims 4 and NHL 15 now the sims 4 isn't a
bad game but it's certainly not the game
that sims fans were looking for my
initial thoughts upon hearing the EA had
dropped the game's open-world pulls
toddlers and customization options and
replaced these things with funny walks
and sim emotions suggested to me that EA
didn't understand what their fans wanted
and why they enjoyed the series The Sims
4 has some interesting new aspects like
the well integrated gallery filled with
custom content and the emotion focused
gameplay which can sometimes be a help
instead of a hindrance he did make a
good call by not pushing the sims 4
online like it did with SimCity an
unpopular decision the company
eventually altered to include an offline
mode but the nature of the game feels
like a betrayal of what myself and other
sims fans expected that is more not less
NHL is another story while we can
attribute this game and the sims force
issues with the fact that the
development existed long before the
player first mantra players still had a
huge problem with the hockey games
launched again NHL 15 for new gen
consoles isn't altogether a bad game
it's a game with some decent features
and some interesting new additions the
sure that gamers are having at the
moment is that the game is unfinished
much like the sims for NHL 15 is missing
many of the little features that fans
have come to enjoy and expect from the
series some fans were given early access
which is awesome but they were the first
to see all the missing features notable
absences on the xbox one and ps4
versions included the popular EA Sports
Hockey League and connected GM modes he
quickly conducted damage control with
NHL producer Sean Ramsey singh posting a
list of features the company intends to
patch back in in the coming months on
the other hand their latest installment
for that other popular sports franchise
which launched last week FIFA 15 seems
to be going down pretty damn well gamers
were able to get their hands on a demo
beforehand which also happens to be the
most played demo in the company's sports
divisions history EA are only three
months into their newly enforced player
first culture so it's fair to give them
some benefit of the doubt just at the
moment that's largely due to the fact
that the lion's share of the development
for this year's releases has taken place
long before the announcement of their
altered company attitude to players the
releases of Dragon Age Inquisition and
battlefield hardline are certainly going
to give us more of an idea of whether or
not the company is making a change on
top of that their recent interesting
keeping game is updated and making
dragon age and battlefield better don't
seem to be a positive adjustment for the
meantime either way will surely be
keeping an eye on where the company goes
from here but let me know what you think
what do you reckon EA can do to prove
themselves to gamers and you think they
can ultimately turn it around leave me
your thoughts and I will catch you next
week
you